(heels clicking)
(upbeat music begins)
- Your relationship status says single.
How long have you been single for?
- (Both) Ah!
(laughs)
- Daddy!
(upbeat music continues)
- I've been separated from Olive's father
since she was a baby.
And that was my last serious relationship
- You do know I'm more
than a Saturday guy, right?
I want to be part of this
family. I really want
to be let in.
- So how about this weekend,
we do anal?
- What? No I meant let in.
That's not what...I mean, I'll do it,
that's what I do.
- Okay.
- So Catherine,
you were unable to make
your relationship work
with true say boy band
star Shepherd Night.
- We've moved on as you can
see, and soon you will too.
- I'm here for you, babe,
if you ever want to talk.
- And I'm here for you if
this is a hostage situation
just blink if you're in trouble.
- Mommy, are you cross about my stepmom?
- No, I didn't have you.
So you belonged to me forever.
Olive can't be an only child.
- That's what Beyonce's parents said.
And then they had Solange.
- Solange is the true visionary
of that family and you know it.
I'm ready to have another baby.
- Uh.
- I need to do this with a sperm donor.
It's the safest way for me.
- What's your reason for
wanting a child in this way?
- My entire family are dead to me.
So when Olive was born, I was all alone.
But now we have each other.
- We have donors in their late teens
and early twenties fit
for a geriatric pregnancy.
- What did you just call me?
- You're going to stick
some pathetic, random
loser's spunk up yourself?
(laughs)
- Yeah, yours.
- What do you mean mine?
- If one of my kids
going to have a shit dad,
both my kids are getting shit dads.
- Ten grand.
- Say nothing and get your dick out.
- I'm not hard.
- Why not?
I wore the outfit.
- Maybe because you're gross
and you keep being yourself.
- Ah!
- You need to sort your family out.
- Amelia is dyslexic so things
can get lost in translation.
- Amelia's dick's lexic.
- I beg your pardon?
- It's almost like you shouldn't be equals
with a nine-year-old,
acting like you're sisters.
- Hey, pretend I said something funny.
(laughs)
- Why?
- That's what grownups do late
at night in pubs. They laugh.
(laughs)
- I was wrong if I ever made you believe
that your dad or I was perfect.
We love you a lot, but we respect you too.
It is not that hard to
be a decent fucking mom.